vamos ahora al problema 103 problemas
103 en este problema nos dicen que en
ica son mayores que 0 y lo que
necesitamos determinar es si n entre k
es un entero o no entre k es entero
pero muy bien en el inciso 1 lo que nos
dicen es que en ica n y que son enteros
son
enteros enteros sale bueno pensemos si
esto es suficiente para determinar si
entre calles entero yo digo que no
porque por ejemplo n podría ser igual a
7 y que podría ser igualados y entonces
esto es 3.5 que no es un entero o bien
podría ser 6 y acá podría ser 3 y
entonces la división queda 2 que si es
entero entonces esta información por sí
misma no es suficiente vamos a ver qué
dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos
dicen que n al cuadrado y k al cuadrado
son enteros son enteros enteros
pero esto no es información nueva de
hecho esta información ya la teníamos
desde arriba si en el casón enteros
entonces claramente n al cuadrado y acá
al cuadrado son enteros y por lo tanto
estos ejemplos también funcionan verdad
es decir tenemos que 7 al cuadrado es
entero 2 al cuadrado es entero pero 7
entre 2 no es entero y lo mismo acá 6 al
cuadrado y 3 al cuadrado son enteros y 6
entre 3 es 2 que si es entero entonces
pues ni siquiera juntando los
podemos responder la pregunta de hecho
pues el segundo es bastante inútil
porque tiene toda la información del
primero vale bueno entonces la respuesta
sería
muy bien pasemos ahora al problema 104
en el problema 104 lo que nos dicen es
que el promedio de 6 números
voy a ponerle prom pro de 6
seis números en números es 75 es 75 y lo
que nos piden determinar es cuántos de
ellos son iguales a 75 cuántos cuántos
son iguales a 75 75 kva esto suena
interesante en el inciso 1 lo que nos
dicen es que ninguno es menor que 75
ninguno
ninguno es menor que 75 con esto
podremos determinar cuántos son iguales
a 75 parece ser muy poca información
pero yo digo que sí y de hecho podemos
mostrar que todos son iguales a 75 como
le vamos a hacer pues observa si ninguno
es menor que 75 entonces tenemos algunos
75 algunos 75 y quizás cosas mayores
verdad porque ninguno es menor que 75
pero imagínate que tenemos por ahí un 78
sale bueno pues este 78 desvía el
promedio de los números hacia arriba
hacia arriba vale pero este 78 ya no sé
ya no se puede compensar con nada más
pequeño porque ningún número es menor
que 75 entonces en realidad este 78 no
puede existir porque si no el promedio
quedaría arriba de 75 y bueno este 78
fue un número más grande pero este mismo
argumento prueba que ningún número más
grande es de 75 puede ser de estos seis
números vale entonces sin ninguno es
menor que 75 todos deben ser igual
a 75 kva entonces esta si nos permite
responder la pregunta y el inciso 2 dice
que ninguno ninguno es mayor que 75 y es
exactamente la misma idea verdad si
tenemos algunos 75 75 y hubiera alguien
menor que 75 173 ahora el promedio se
iría hacia abajo de 75 y ya no se puede
compensar porque hay números porque
están prohibidos los números arriba de
75 vale entonces este 73 ni ninguna cosa
abajo de 75 puede estar entre los 6
números y por lo tanto todos son iguales
a 75 entonces este también funciona
entonces la respuesta sería sería d
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 105 de
problema 105 simplemente nos piden
determinar si el valor absoluto de x el
valor absoluto de x es igual h - z
- z déjame bajar un poco ok vamos a ver
que nos dan de información en el inciso
1 nos dicen que x + es igual a z esto
será suficiente para respondernos a esta
pregunta bueno pues vamos a sustituir z
aquí arriba para ver realmente que nos
estamos preguntando una vez que tenemos
esta información nos estamos preguntando
si el valor absoluto de x es igual hay
menos x más
x más o sea si el valor absoluto de x es
igual a menos x
la aie se cancela con ya con la ye
entonces nos estamos preguntando si el
valor absoluto de x es igual a menos x y
esto no podemos respondernos lo todavía
sí porque no sabemos si x es positivo o
negativo si x fuera positivo esto sería
falso y si x fuera negativo esto sería
verdadero porque al sacarle el valor
absoluto a un número negativo cambia su
signo que o sea aquí nos quedaría igual
a 3 que es lo mismo que multiplicar por
menos uno menos menos tres vale y con
los positivos no sucede esto bueno la
cosa es que todavía no podemos no
podemos responder esta pregunta vamos a
ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2
nos dicen que x es menor que cero pues
esto ya es suficiente para responder si
esto se cumple o no y de hecho si se
cumple verdad si x es menor que cero
como vimos acá el valor absoluto de x
justo consiste en cambiarle el signo
entonces combinando las dos tenemos la
respuesta y así la respuesta sería sí
vale la respuesta sería sí y por
supuesto el inciso 2 por el inciso 2 por
sí mismo no nos permite responder porque
no tiene nada que ver con yo ni con z
bueno vamos ahora al problema
106 problemas 106 en el problema 106 nos
preguntan por la ganancia
voy a poner aquí g
que tuvo un cine al vender 400 boletos
algunos de ellos a precio total y
algunos de ellos a un precio de
descuento que acabó siendo x por ciento
o sea ese precio x por ciento del precio
total vale bueno entonces déjame poner
algunas variables vamos a suponer que el
cine vendió n a precio normal y vendió
de a precio de descuento
entonces nos dicen que vendió en total
400 400 y lo que nosotros queremos es
determinar la ganancia vale y la
ganancia está dada por x pues los que
vendió a precio normal a precio normal
vamos a ponerle que el precio normal era
p multiplicados por p verdad entonces
esto es cuánto ganó por los de precio
normal ya eso hay que sumarle x por p
porque este es el precio de descuento
multiplicado por los que vendió en
descuento esto es lo que nos gustaría
determinar vale
vamos a ver qué información nos dan en
el inciso 1 nos dicen que x es igual a
50 ok
x es igual a 50 entonces esta ecuación
se convertiría en p por n + más o sea si
x es el 50% voy a ponerlo aquí como 0.5
0.5 p por d esto todavía no nos dice
gran cosa verdad tenemos todavía varias
variables aquí tenemos la p la n y la de
entonces esto todavía no responde la
pregunta y en el inciso 2 lo que nos
dice es que el precio de los boletos de
precio normal era de 20 pesos entonces
nos están diciendo que p p es igual a 20
sale entonces pues haber incluso
juntando la información 1 con la 2a que
llegaríamos vamos a ver me parece que
todavía no no no podemos responder la
pregunta porque aquí p sería 20
tendríamos 20 n
+ 10 de 10 d
y bueno también sabemos que en más de
400 pero eso no nos dice gran cosa
verdad porque todavía aquí tenemos pues
otros 10 cn a lo mejor si esto fuera 10
n 10 d quedó muy fea esa de déjame
ponerle un poco más bonita si esto fuera
10 n 10 d pues nada más multiplicamos
esto por 10 y ya lo tendríamos pero este
25 modo y de hecho me parece que a
partir de aquí no podemos decir nada
vale entonces incluso sabiendo cuál es
el porcentaje del boleto en descuento y
el precio del boleto normal todavía no
podemos responder la pregunta porque nos
queda esta expresión no se me está
pasando nada no según yo no haber x 50
ponemos aquí 0.5 ps20 ponemos 20 y 10
tenemos esta expresión y tenemos esto no
todavía no podemos decir nada tenemos
las variables gen n y de y pues de esas
pues nada más tenemos tenemos dos
ecuaciones si je je igual a esto que
igual a esto en de más de igual a 400
son tres variables dos ecuaciones
entonces no
siquiera juntando la información de los
dos incisos podemos responder y entonces
la respuesta sería y bueno seguimos con
estos problemas en el próximo vídeo